uh first of all thanks to the organizers
for for this wonderful workshop and
giving me this
opportunity
and uh also I'd like to acknowledge uh
abip with whom uh I've done several
projects and part of those projects I
included in this overview talk and I'll
also like to uh thank Adam with whom we
had several discussions and suggest and
he has suggested several things that
held in um formulating several problems
in the
uh in this work okay so in this talk I
will um discuss uh and this very simple
and generic learning uh Theory framework
called empirical risk minimization and
then I'll talk about how differential
privacy fits in this framework and how
this framework gives a very sort of
natural and simple to understand um
context for differential privacy it will
give us very crisp and precise goals as
to what we want from our differentially
private ERM algorithm and then I'll talk
about uh two very popular algorithms in
this uh area called output perturbation
and objective perturbation both of these
algorithms were initially proposed by
this very nice work by Kika Chri CLA
mononi and Anan svat and then I'll very
briefly discuss uh stochastic gradient
decent methods which can be sort of
thought of as more practical uh
algorithms for solving these
differential privacy uh or privacy
preserving empirical risk minimation
type of problems and I'll briefly talk
about uh some other empirical risk
minimation settings called kernel
function based empirical risk minimation
and then I'll conclude with summary and
some open problems that I think are
interesting so let me start with some
very um basic uh learning problems so
let's say I have a classification task
where a bunch of images let's say of
chimpan and human beings and I want to
learn a classifier so that given a uh
image I want to figure out you know what
is the label of this image so here I
have data points and the prediction that
I want is whether um a image is um
belongs to class one or class two uh now
I need not have this um discrete
prediction I can have more continuous
prediction so here let's say I have a
data point that is represented by one
variable and on y AIS on uh I have the
predicted variable and now I want uh and
this y variable that I'm trying to
predict can be continuous and I just
want to figure out uh given X how do I
come up with a reasonable value for y
okay and things can get much more
complicated such as let's say ranking
where let's say you go to any search
engine type some query and then the
search engine will show a rank list of
documents so now uh how do you how the
search engine comes with this uh list or
how with this ranking so again this is a
simple learning problem uh and uh in all
these problems what happens is that um I
have a I want to select a hypothesis
from a fixed class W and I'm given some
uh instances uh or some training data um
let's say X1 y1 X2 Y2 and so on till X
and YN and here uh XI represents the
data point and Y represents the
prediction that I want to make um or my
target variable that I want to predict
and now the goal is um goal in learning
is to come up with a function that will
that given X1 will predict y1 or given
XI predict Yi
okay so um here uh if you do not make
any assumptions on how training data is
sampled or how training data is coming
then it's hard to study the problem so a
uh very simple um and generic framework
here is to uh consider a um a uniform
sampling um based approach where uh what
I'll assume is that each data point XI
Yi is sampled from a fixed distribution
D okay and now I also have a loss
function that for given uh hypothesis uh
will tell me how well I did for an
instance X so whether uh my in
prediction on this data point x
according to this variable W or this uh
hypothesis parameter W matches y or not
okay and now my goal will be uh in
expectation uh minimize the risk that is
incurred uh by my hypothesis selection
by my selected
hypothesis okay so this uh quantity I
will call as the risk um
and now if I knew the distribution maybe
I can directly try to optimize uh this
quantity but problem is that I do not
know the distribution I only have the
training data so I'll use my training
samples as a proxy for the distribution
that is rather other than directly
trying to uh minimize uh the risk what
I'll do is I'll compute my empirical
risk and try to minimize that so I have
these training data points XI yis Each
Coming IID from the distribution I'll
try to minimize this average loss of my
w over these set of training
instances okay uh so here in this talk I
will um mostly focus on uh cases where
my loss function is a convex loss
function which uh which is not
necessarily the best thing in practice
typically so for example let's say
classification I want my
misclassification rate to be very small
and misclassification rate is non-convex
but then in learning theory people have
come up with this surrogate loss
functions or convex relaxations of these
uh non-convex loss functions and what
they say is that okay I'll try to
minimize or focus on this convex
arrogate and then because of this convex
relaxation I will have some extra error
that that they will try to uh separately
measure or separately uh
estimate yeah is the L function conx
also in the y or just in the XI and W in
wxi Yi also Yi yeah so xiyi can be
thought of as just one uh instance
usually for linear threshold you
multiply Yi by wxi yeah so that's
something that uh I'll just consider
that entire space and I'll just focus on
W for now uh okay so
so uh now so what I can try to do is I
can optimize the empirical risk now
however uh even though if my loss
function is convex still I can have
multiple Solutions and some solutions
might be more desirable than the others
so I can try to uh regularize or I can
try to uh guide my search to a
particular type of solution that I think
will be very good and might have a small
uh risk uh in future or on my test
samples so um basically the standard
idea is to add some sort of
regularization so um what I'll do is
I'll uh try to uh in this empirical risk
I'll add a regularization function so
here RW will be called I'll try I'll
call it regation function and Lambda is
the regulation parameter okay so RW is a
fixed
function that I'm assuming is let's say
one strongly convex and what is strong
convexity guarantees is that now I have
a unique solution to this problem
I cannot have multiple Solutions and RW
is in some sense putting a prior on what
type of solutions I'm looking for okay
and Lambda is my regulation parameter
that I'll uh set appropriately to get
best
results either using some sort of
validation set or using my theoretical
bounds okay so uh let me explain what do
I mean by uh strongly convex well uh
what it sort of says is that um if I
have a um so if this this is my function
RW then I draw a gradient at w then my
function value at w Prime is at least uh
this W primeus w² larger than what I
would have got here at the
gradient and that is considering it to
be linear function so it says that my
function is um growing much faster as I
go far away from my Optima and that
helps guide the search process very well
and in fact also ensures uh uniqueness
of the
Optima okay so um throughout this talk I
will assume that we are trying to solve
this regularized uh empirical risk
minimization problem uh and uh let me
now give some of some concrete examples
for this problem uh like you know for um
some instances of uh regularized erms um
that are very popular in practice so one
of the most popular example is support
VOR machines where the loss function is
what we call hinge loss so so it can be
thought of as a convex relaxation of the
01 loss that I earlier talked about so
it looks something like this rather than
this okay um and the regulation function
here is just a two nor of the parameter
Vector W
okay another uh very popular um uh
learning U problem is L2 regularize
logistic regression logistic regression
is can also be thought of as a
relaxation of the 01 hinge loss oh sorry
01 misclassification law however uh this
is a slightly more smooth uh loss
function it is differentiable so in
certain uh type of analysis that helps
and it also helps in guiding the uh
optimization
procedure okay and then final example is
uh the standard Ridge regression where
the loss function is um L2 Le squares SL
function and again the regulation
function is the L2 regulation function
okay all right um so uh as I said that
uh in reality we want to solve this uh
uh true risk or population risk but what
we are doing is either empirical risk or
regularized risk
minimization okay so the question is uh
uh how much are we going to lose because
of this and because of this finite
number of samples uh how much excess
error I'm going to incur
so for these uh um problems uh there
exist several results some very generic
results that bounce the excess error
incurred because of solving uh a proxy
problem to the original problem okay so
uh one of the most popular result here
comes from this work by Shai shishas and
colleagues so there they say that okay
um let's say I fix the distribution D
and I'm assuming that if data point x X
and Y are sampled from this distribution
then almost surely Norm of X is bounded
by some quantity BX and similarly let's
say I will focus myself on um uh looking
at this hypothesis from this fixed
hypothesis class W and I'm assuming that
uh Norm of every Vector W in this
hypothesis class is bounded by
BW okay and uh I'll also assume that the
loss function is convex and ellipses
that is um if I VAR W1 slightly then the
loss function does not change too
much okay so under these assumptions um
and uh over the um probability of uh
over the randomness of sampling uh these
training data points uh what we can say
is that for every W in my hypothesis
class the population risk is very close
to the empirical risk and the closeness
or the excess risk that we are getting
is this much so this goes down as
something like 1 by root n and it has
this quantity of lipsus constant and the
radius of the ball in which we are
working so this is
um uh so this is uh very similar to the
chof bound only issue is that now we are
taking a soup or W so uh the W can
itself depend on all the variables so in
some sense uh what this bound is doing
is it is taking uh a covering number
argument or doing a covering number
argument in a slightly intelligent
fashion so that uh explicit
dimensionality is not showing up
dimensionality is in some sense
implicitly showing up in terms of the
Norms of um X and
W yeah so the star is any arbitrary Norm
uh yeah sorry so if I'm measuring X in
some Norm then a star is the Dual Norm
of it it's dual
Norm okay and what's the quantification
on C I'm sorry what is the
quantification on C C is any constant I
I didn't put to use before what uh so C
is a global constant um it's like H it's
like
seven
seven um
42 it's small it's not
that really like so um so now this says
that uh my empirical risk and um sample
risk uh is differs by something like 1
by root and only and um this is also in
learning theory it's also called uniform
convergence bound because it holds for
every W uh in my hypothesis class so now
let's say uh I'm doing empirical risk
minimization I obtain W Tilda by solving
this proxy problem whereas W star is the
optimal thing that I can do yeah in the
last in the last slide did you did
you so
we're you're bounding the norm of X but
uh you know are you assuming anything
about the form of the loss function or
no here you here you don't need to
assume
anything um for this just just that it's
lip shits for every pair
yeah so um okay so uh now the quick
question on follow up on that it's not
lip shs in X and Y only in W only in w
yes it can very wiely with X yeah so why
does the norm of X have anything to do
with
it usually we assume that the LI shits
continuity thing uh is L time the norm
of X time the Dual Norm of W1 minus
W2 oh okay yeah yeah I think sorry
so
yeah so it should be L * BX
something um so now because we are
uh so we are trying to find out the best
or we are trying to compare ourselves
with respect to the um best W star for
uh sample risk whereas let's say we find
out a w Tilda by doing this empirical
risk minimation so now what we can say
is that because my empirical risk and
true risk is so close and for because
I'm doing this uh optimization over
empirical risk that's why RN w t will
always be less than RN W star and that's
why what it will say is that if I do
empirical risk then the excess risk that
I'm getting is of this
type okay so now let's say when I'm
handling this regularized empirical risk
minimization then I have some more
structure because I know that my
objective function is strongly convex so
in that that case can I improve my
bounds and the answer is yes but in some
restricted sense so again the
assumptions are similar uh again I think
you have L and the norm of X
here and uh we are assuming that L is
one strongly convex so in that case what
you can show say is that if W hat is the
minimizer of this regularized
ERM then objective function value of w
hat is less than the best objective
function Value Plus some something that
goes down as 1
byn okay so uh this rate is much better
that is I'm getting uh this rate at 1
byn rather than 1 byoot n but I can make
this statement only for w hat for my
minimizer only I cannot make it for any
arbitrary W so I don't have uniform
convergence in uh that sense okay so but
this still seems very
uh um um weird that uh I know that if I
even if for a fixed W my shern B cannot
give anything better than 1 by root then
how am I uh getting this uh extra thing
so well answer is that because now uh
when I'm doing this uh uh risk
minimization I also I also have this
extra factor of the regulation parameter
so here when I'm trying to bound RW head
this will be bounded by RW Star Plus
this extra regulation parameter and then
I have to set Lambda properly to balance
set out and when I try to set Lambda
appropriately it will turn out to be
something of the order 1 by root and
that's why again the rate that I'll
observe will be 1 by root
only but now nice thing is that in my
rate what I will have is uh R of w so it
won't be uh the um so the in earlier
case the bound was in terms of the uh
radius of the hypothesis class now it
won't be that it will be what is the
minimum possible of RW for a good um um
minimizer so let's say if I had uh 100
uh minimizers um of my empirical risk
then out of those 100 minimizers
whatever minimizer had the minimum value
for RW I can use that
okay all right so now having set up
having you know U explained all the
empirical risk minimization framework
let me just set the notation so that now
we can move on to differential priv
privacy uh versions of um this uh uh
empirical risk minimization problems so
I'll assume that the data is in my data
set I have n Points each of the point is
in R to power D I'll assume that Norm of
X is less than equal to 1 and uh each of
the data point is sample from this
distribution D and empirical risk uh
sample risk um bounds are anyways clear
and uh uniform convergence bound gives
us this rate of 1 by root 10 uh and then
W star throughout the talk I will use
for the best minimizer or um best
solution for my real problem that is
true risk minimizing problem and W hat
will be the optimal solution to this
regularized ERM problem okay and we have
this Bound for w for the excess risk
incurred by W hat
okay all right so moving on um so now we
want to have we want to solve this
empirical risk minimation problem but
while preserving privacy of each of my
data point so in uh so here in this
empirical reation problem what's going
on is I have these training sets I have
will have a learning algorithm that will
output this W hat and what I want is
that this W hat is differentially
private with respect to the given data
set and furthermore um my algorithm or
the W hat has the risk of w head will be
small okay exess risk is small okay so
now there is a question that why is it
even possible like um why do we think or
what is the intuition why we think um
that um we will be able to achieve this
task so well the idea is that we added
the regularization just to ensure that
we do not overit to the data that is our
hypothesis is stable to small changes in
the data and that's precisely the uh
type of condition that you want your
differential private algorithm to have
so uh so so um I'll try to precisely
State what do I mean by this stability
and how and I also actually give the
proof it's the proof is like just three
lines so I'll give this uh and I'll call
this LMA economic stability LMA that
Adam called in his talk yesterday clear
I don't deserve any credit for no no so
I'm not saying that it's just that the
nomenclature is the first time I heard
so I thought it's a cool name and it
comes again and again so maybe we should
have a name for it so let's say uh I
obtain W Hat
by uh by solving this problem over data
set D and let's say I have another data
set D Prime that varies or that is
different from d in only one data point
and for Simplicity we'll assume that
only nth point is different okay and if
we use this data set D Prime then my
solution will be W hat sorry W Prime
okay and now by stability what we mean
is we want to bound how much W hat and W
Prime can
differ okay and the LMA is that it
differs as something like 1 by Lambda
not L by Lambda so the proof is
extremely simple because we know that
for this objective function J W hat is
the optimal so for all W's uh this
quantity is greater than equal to zero
and by strong convexity I know that um
my objective function at w is less than
objective function at w prime plus the
gradient plus the strong cor mixity term
now gradient is always greater than
equal to Zer so I can ignore it and I
will obtain this equation and similarly
uh I'll use same equation but for my uh
second optimization problem that is for
this optimization problem because W
Prime is optimal for this so I will
obtain a analogous equation
here okay and now I add these equations
up the regulation parameter or the
regularization uh functions cancel out
and what I will observe is something
like
RN W hatus RN Prime W hat and RN W
primeus RN Prime W Prime and I want to
bound them but note that uh because uh
my data sets D and D Prime differ in
only one entry so RN wus rnw Prime is
given by exactly
this uh for all W's so we apply this
twice and that's why um this n * Lambda
W Prime W squ is given by some of these
loss functions and then we use the
property that L is lipes and that will
give us this bound and we cancel out w
primeus w head from both the sides and
we show that uh the um W Prime and W hat
are at differ by at most 1 by
Lambda so as my data points are
increasing or if my regulation parameter
increases then uh there is the two
things are most stable and now because
uh we know that if my output that I'm
giving is stable or has uh can has this
type of sensitivity then I can add noise
of that level and make the algorithm
differentially private so that's
precisely what this uh algorithm called
output perturbation does which was first
proposed um in this work by uh CMS 11
and rbht 11 so the algorithm is
extremely simple let's say this is the
objective function that I'm trying to
minimize and for Simplicity let's say um
I don't have any constraints and all so
w hat will be the optimizer so w private
is uh W hat plus Some
Noise Okay and in this work of cms1 they
propos to use the gamma noise
or
okay so uh what they show is that this
output perturbation algorithm which is
extremely simple is Epsilon
differentially private and furthermore
uh the utility guarantee is of this type
okay so um here the utility is in some
sense optimal in terms of N and
Epsilon uh but there are two um
interesting terms appearing in the
numerator one is a d so if you remember
in uh the excess risk bounds that we
give for non private uh empirical risk
minimization we didn't have any factor
of D it was characterized by how my how
the norm over my set look like sorry you
say that's op optimal in terms of
Epsilon yeah I mean one by
is um that seems strange to me because
we can get those types of results in the
local model uh the global model we
should have much better dependence on
Epsilon
right Epsilon might go in the inside the
square root also I'm not sure about
that model the epon N inside Square Ro
uh so it feels like in the global model
our dependence on Epsilon should be much
much better I mean that's what I think
that's what we us I don't remember of
any result that has something like 1 by
root n
EP but but we don't know if that's
optimal though okay so I take that I'm
asking so it seem like I don't know that
that's pretty good dependence
but I'm not sure just well how about in
one dimension I think you could probably
in one dimension I think it should be
one on root n plus one on Epsilon s
n I think because the amount of noise I
add in one dimension if things are sort
of one on N sensitive is 1/ Epsilon squ
is much
worse uh but but I have an n on the
bottom of that um it's okay it's
fine seems the best I seen is so no one
is no one has the an immediate answer so
that's fine that
sounds epon
goes okay so there are two quantities
here one is that um we have uh this term
W star or two nor of w star and then
there's a dependence on
dimensionality so this dependence on
dimensionality is something undesirable
but uh this dependence on W star is very
interesting so this sort of says that um
if let's say my optimal solution has
very small law then um even my
differential private algorithm will have
uh fairly good uh excess risk right and
this W star in some sense characterizes
how hard the problem is so for example
in the case of support Vector machine uh
problem or in case of this binary
classification problem my margin is
given by one by Norm of w star okay so
if the margin is large
that is if the problem is easier then uh
the norm of w star is
smaller okay so uh that is correctly
characterized by uh this bound although
the exponent 4 by3 might not be optimal
okay so uh later on um in this work by
kefir Smith and takura um they propos to
use gsan noise instead of the gamma
noise
and that immediately buys them a root D
Factor here and but they lose in terms
of privacy guarantees that is now you
will have only Epson Delta differential
privacy so now the question is that can
we do better can we get rid of um this D
entirely so in recent work with abip we
showed that if we assume that uh we have
generalized linear model that is the way
W and so basically uh we have a linear
model and L is just a convex function
over this linear model and if the
regularizer is the L2 n regularizer then
uh using the same goian noise we'll have
a Delta differential privacy but um the
dependence on W star is now optimal and
there's no dependence on
D okay and here I would like to stress
that the generalized linear model is
very important because in general if you
are trying to solve the problem getting
rid of D might not be possible for
example if you are Computing mean of n
vectors that itself will throw in a
dependence on D but because we are just
restricted ourselves to linear model
generalized linear model which is very
common in learning problems like in fact
almost all the learning problems of
Interest like classification regression
Etc has generalized linear model so so
that is well motivated yeah is this um
specific to this this this bound is
specific to expected risk is that right
yeah this is specific to so if you if
you wanted like high probability bounds
that that Dimension might crop up again
is that correct no but you cannot do any
better than expected risk right so this
is uh true risk uh as in on any sample
of from my distribution uh what will be
my loss I think the question is what's
the probability that private is actually
bigger than the terms on the right hand
side so the probability will be uh um
well it will be a constant probability
only um we cannot guarantee more than
better than constant um but we can get
something that is uh decreasing in D by
adding a extra log
Factor so I'll show you how the
probability comes in
and so uh the observation is extremely
simple that because we have uh this
um uh output peration algorithm so uh
whenever we try to measure how different
uh the prediction of w private on X will
be from W hat X well that is given by
precisely by inner product of B which is
a gan noise with X and because B is a
gan noise so inner product of B comma X
and B is independent of X so this random
variable now doesn't have any dependence
on D it's just a n0 uh variance
random variable and now here we bounded
this by something like by L by L Lambda
Epsilon using constant probability but
if you want something that is going down
with dimensionality you have to add an
extra log D
here uh and now because my loss function
is uh lipsus so uh the difference
between the loss function is bounded by
how different uh the prediction or
projection onto Vector
X's okay and this will then using
uniform convergence bounds will
immediately imply that um the risk at w
private is less than equal to risk at w
hat plus a term of this type okay and
then using bound on RW head and then
trading off our Lambda properly we
obtain the this uh utility guarantee or
this excess risk
guarantee Okay so the proof is
okay all right so uh let me move on to
now another algorithm which is uh
objective perturbation so the issue with
output perturbation is that it seems
like um you have completely solved the
problem uh and then you are adding some
noise and it might so happen that maybe
the data was also very well conditioned
might have good condition number and in
that case uh we are unnecessarily adding
too much of noise so if we uh part up
output sorry objective function itself
then maybe if the data is well
conditioned then that will automatically
uh give us better results so that was
sort of the intuition behind uh doing
this out objective peration algorithm so
what we do is this is our original
objective function and we'll add a small
noise to
it and in terms of um geometry what it
says is that if this function is the
true objective function that I want to
minimize and let's say w hat is the true
minimizer then uh my gradient will be
equal to minus B for this objective
function and W private will be given by
this point wherever the gradient um
intersects this uh
curve so now for this algorithm uh this
work of cms1 showed that the algorithm
has Epsilon differential privacy because
they add this gamma noise and
furthermore the excess this uh that they
obtain is of the order of the type w
star d by
routen okay and then uh this work by kst
12 showed that if you addan noise then
you can indeed do better you have
something like root d by ro 10 with this
W star okay and this work also um
improved analysis of uh this work by uh
K and co-authors in a very significant
manner so that work needed to assume
that the objective function is
differentiable especially the um the
regularization needs to be
differentiable where this work showed
that you do not need that property and
that was very critical because they were
interested in sparse linear regression
where uh the regularization function
need not be
differentiable okay uh also I'd like to
mention that because uh we are adding
Gan noise so you will obtain only Epson
Delta
differentialy okay so maybe you said it
on the previous slide but this method
also requires
so this is not actual method like you
need to add some uh like regularization
also small amount
of right but doesn't it also requires
some
um some extra smoothness on this the
little Lo on little on little l no
doesn't it yeah you'll need uh that L is
the H of L is bounded um yeah so I'm
ignoring that for now uh okay so
all right so but so this is very good
but still um we are getting this extra
root D factor and the question is can we
uh get rid of that so answer is yes but
under well uh definitely we need to
assume generalized Lum model but we also
need to make two very sort of
restrictive assumptions or they are um
reasonable assumptions but we would like
to relax them so one is that the uh
regularization function is L2 Nall or
sorry L2 square and the problem is
unconstrained
um so under these assumptions what we
can show is that you can obtain uh a
excess risk bound which is not dependent
on D and which is dependent on W Star as
the optimal risk
bound that is non private version of it
so the only extra factor that we are
getting is root log 1 by Delta divided
byep okay can you remind me how this
compared to the
outut so this matches exactly the output
peration
problem but in practice um this method
tends to be much much better than
peration because it is able to utilize
the uh intrinsic um strong convexity in
the data points
itself okay so let me give a very brief
proof sketch of um uh for um this
analysis so uh remember that we have
this output perturbation um sorry
objective perturbation and then we have
this L2 loss function and we have
unconstraint problem and that's why what
we can say is we can sort of rewrite
this optimization Problem by just
clubbing uh these two terms together and
then I'll add B by Lambda and subtract B
by Lambda okay so now uh uh we will
treat this W + B by Lambda as one
variable V and we can Define this new
loss function which is also a empirical
uh regularized empirical risk
minimization problem slightly part up
than our original one and what we have
is that if vlda is the optimizer of this
regularized empirical risk mantion
problem then W private and vlda are
related by this um
quantity just looking for L of time so
this is Lambda I think should be comma
and it's
uh
okay so so now that we have this uh
characterization of w prate and weer so
closely what we can do is we can for
this uh regularized ERM we can apply uh
the excess risk
bound which I
presented few minutes back um and uh
recall that uh this risk bound also
dependent on the norm of the vector so
that comes as inner product of BX by
Lambda Square I'm assuming the norm of X
is one
okay and now uh we know that h of V
shilda is equal to the sample risk at w
private plus some regularization which
is positive so we can ignore that and on
the right hand side we have something
like uh risk at w star minus B by Lambda
plus Norm of w star okay and because uh
my loss function is lipsus and I have
generalized L model so I can um relate
empirical risk at w star minus B by
Lambda at and empirical risk at w star
uh and the difference will be something
of the order in a product of b x by
Lambda time
something
okay and again we'll use the same fact
that because X is independent of B and B
is a cauan vector so this quantity is of
at most of let's say order log B with
probability that is decreasing
polinomial in D okay and that will
complete
the all right so uh let me now briefly
present some experimental evaluation uh
for these two type of algorithms so one
approach is do output or objective
perturbation but um with gamma noise so
these are given by this um black curve
and blue curve and do this output and
objective peration but with Gan noise
and here we can see that uh if let's say
we artificially boost the dimensionality
of these algorithms or sorry of the data
set so our original data set is in only
8 Di ions but we just padded it with
zeros and just because of this padding
the um original output and objective
perturbation algorithms um performance
decreases very sharply whereas uh this
gion noise based method Still Remains at
the same level of accuracy another very
important point to notice that there's a
big difference between the performance
of objective perturbation and output
perturbation so the Baseline accuracy is
around 91% and objective peration is
able to you almost that accuracy but
output perturbation is like 15% lesser
than
that okay so uh so so far uh what we did
was we considered this uh empirical risk
minimization problem consider these two
um very generic algorithms and we showed
that if we have uh L2 regularizations on
this problem on um on uh in our problem
then end the problem is con then we can
have a excess risk bound that is
independent of
dimensionality but uh then we wanted to
consider some other problems where you
know let's say my regulation parameter
is something different so another very
popular regulation parameter is the
entropy so now what I will try to do is
I will try to do uh optimization over
the Simplex or the probability simplex
and the regulation parameter is the
entropy uh of this Pro distribution or
negative entropy of the uh distribution
so uh we want to understand what will be
the excess risk of this regularized DRM
and there exist several motivations for
this entropy regularized empiric minion
for example in uh several machine
learning problems like facial expression
and also by analyzing such um by
analyzing this problem we were able to
improve regret guarantees for the online
experts problem in differential privacy
context go ahead
um is there some relation between the
choice of the regularizer and the norm
that you choose to the norm constraint
for w like there like a general
principle yeah there's a simple
principle that is your regularization
should be strongly convex in the norm
which was the requirement yeah um so
whatever Norm you select so let's say
entropy is strongly convex with respect
to the L1 n so um so over your
hypothesis class now you'll try to put
your El norm and now on the ball from
which your instances are drawn you'll
put the Dual n that is the infinity noun
and that's a very general principle and
um like that principle has been explored
very well in learning theory and uh
optimizing
literature
okay so now for this problem we do not
use objective pertubation or um uh
output perturbation we came up with a
sort of um different type of algorithm
based on sampling and that seem to give
us very good dependence on
dimensionality
so the algorithm is very simple that um
because I'm learning this W hat which is
a probity distribution so it will look
something like this uh overd
Dimensions now what we'll do is we'll
sample this distribution M times okay uh
with this probility distribution so
we'll have these M
samples and now the estimated uh
probability Vector that we want to give
and which we want to claim is
differentially private is just given by
uh summation of this samples but like or
canonical vectors of the samples so here
EI means I canonical Vector that is it's
one in the I for coordinate and zero
everywhere else so one immediate thing
to not is that the in expectation our
private uh output is still same as W
hat okay so now uh let's see if we can
uh show some U uh privacy guarantees for
this algorithm so one thing to notice
that if I take infinite samples of from
this distribution that is if n tends to
Infinity then I cannot hope for any
differential privacy because I'm giving
you back exact W head so I have to bound
the number of uh samples that I can take
so the the way we bound the number of
samples is given by this and we also use
the fact that because the algorithm is
entropy regularized or the ERM is
entropy regularized so it will tend to
push towards uniform distribution and
furthermore so so that brings in some
sort of regularity over the um
probability space and uh furthermore we
can sort of say that uh the probability
Vector that we have is of this
particular type so this looks um
suspiciously similar to a exponential
mechanism we can use analysis similar to
exponential mechanism uh
apply strong composition theorem and get
Epson Delta differential
privacy and and one thing to not is that
we also have to assume that the loss
function that we are using is uh smooth
that is the gradient of loss function is
also uh lipes is lipes
continuous okay so this is the Privacy
guarantee and now for utility guarantee
we just sort of use chob bound because
we are taking these M samples and we are
averaging them and we know that in
expectation it is exactly same as W hat
so using chernof type of bound of
argument we get um this type of loss so
the key thing in uh this excess error is
that the dependence on dimensionality is
just logarithmic which is optimal even
for um non-private algorithm even a
non-private algorithm will have log
dependence on um d uh however our
dependence on n and Epsilon is very poor
here so in in particular our dependence
on N is something like 1x3 which is
certainly suboptimal and uh it is
certainly an open problem to um make
this better but one interesting thing
about this is that uh the way we
estimate W private is by taking this by
adding this n um canonical um basis
vectors and that's why we can bound the
number of non zero roughly by n^ 2x3 so
if my dimensionality is very large then
the private the private output that we
obtain is very sparse even though the
original Vector W hat was dense
so this uh is very interesting because
now when I'm trying to at the prediction
time uh the prediction cost is very
small because I have to just take
something like order n^ 2x3 U
multiplications and add them rather than
doing order D computation so this is
interesting that uh differential
privacy uh so rather than um doing exact
computation and then perturbing it if we
are saying that okay we'll already perur
of computation
uh then that might help in several
aspects for differential privacy for
example here it's helping in the
prediction
cost so what should be the right
dependence on N should be depend root
n all right so let me summarize uh the
results that we have uh seen so so far
um
for for various uh regularized empirical
risk minimization um algorith that we
have seen so if we have output
perturbation with GMA noise then we have
correct dependence on N but there's a
dependence on D and dependence on W star
is also not correct but if we have
output perturbation with Gan noise and
in generalized inia model then we have
the correct dependence on both W star n
and n n d and similarly if we have
objective peration with gamma noise then
we have a dependence on
D but uh if you have objective
perturbation with go noise generalized L
model and L2 regularization then uh the
dependence on D goes away and the
dependence on W star is also optimal and
finally if we are solving ANM that is
regularized by entropy and is constrain
to lie on Pro Simplex then our
dependence on D is optimal but our
dependence on N is still sub optimal so
this is the summary of results that we
have seen so
far so so far uh like in both output
perturbation objective perturbation and
even in the sampling based algorithm we
assumed that we solved an optimization
problem exactly and then we perturb it
or uh solve an perturb problem but uh
one main issue with that approach is
that in practice we do not have optimal
solution um from an oracle we have to
run some sort of optimization algorithm
and there is a budget on how long we can
run that
algorithm so uh and these algorithms or
these analysis directly does not
guarantee that if let's say I stopped
after let's say 50 iterations uh what
will be my privacy guarantees so we need
to study uh some more uh like uh need to
study differential privacy of the
iterative algorithms that are popular in
practice uh to say that okay these
iterative algorithms are also reasonable
from differential privacy point of view
so there has been a lot of work in this
direction so in the standard model uh
that is uh where you know you are
outputting just one uh W hat and uh all
the data is with one um server or one
learner and there uh in this work with
abip and PR we showed that uh stochastic
optimization methods have differential
privacy and had reasonable utility
guarantee and then in the local model
where um the um the um uh data the
person who has the data does not even
trust the learner there uh John and
Michael Jordan and Martin VRI has some
results for stochastic radient methods
and um couple of days back Anan
presented some results for mini batch
version of the stochastic gradient desel
methods okay so let me very briefly
describe uh the stochastic gradient
desent method and how we can just add
noise to obtain uh uh differential
privacy guarantees here so uh let's say
this is our regularized empirical risk
minimization problem now typically we
will try to do gradient descent here and
uh how problem is that the gradient
descent is uh very expensive because I
have to compute this gradient over end
points and all of them are in D
Dimension so it might be of order andd
so the Learning Community sort of um
seems like have converged to this um
solution that yes let's use a stochastic
version of this gradient so rather than
Computing the entire gradient I'll
select one data point from my data set
and uh compute its gradient and update
the solution and in expectation I'm
doing the correct thing and it so turns
out that that um with high probability
also uh this will give a good result
okay and the way to analyze such
algorithms is yeah so after how many for
what values of T so what I've seen in
literature is sort of a comparison of
what you get with the batch version with
end points versus stochastic version
within log end
points sorry um so so what this does is
that um so you have to select TAA to be
let's say something of the order 1 by
root t or 1 by T depending on your loss
function is strongly convex or not and
what it says is that if I want a quick
and dirty solution then this algorithm
is very fast but if I want exact
solution then after some iterations this
algorithm will not like the um progress
that it makes is very slow but uh the
true gradient descent will be much
faster however uh one argument for for
this stochastic methods is that and the
data that I observe is anyways noisy so
why do I want to optimize it completely
and that's why uh such methods have
become very
popular okay and later in the talk I
will um uh tell you about an algorithm
which doesn't even respect this like it
does not even respect the regularization
parameter and that also like people have
shown Works reasonably well at least for
the learning and statistical setting
Okay so in terms of differential privacy
well uh in the standard model what we
can do is uh after T steps when we are
happy that maybe we have a reasonable
solution We'll add noise and give the
output and the Privacy proof comes
through the stability of online learning
and utility proof comes from uh the
standard online to batch conversion I
won't have time to go in that today uh
as for local model um you can add a
small amount of noise to the gradient
and uh then again similar conversion
results so and this is a pan private
model that is um at every point of time
the solution that you have is um
differentially private that is even if
you look into the server uh you won't
find uh you won't be able to violate
privacy of any data point okay so let me
very briefly mention this uh um annoying
thing of parameter tuning because uh in
practice when you are trying to solve
this problem uh you have to tune
parameters and that will uh require
several RS of the data so one option is
to do some sort of exponential mechanism
which was proposed in this work by Baska
lakman Smith and takura and then
recently and like couple of days back we
yesterday we heard this very nice talk
by kolika which seems to suggest that we
can use some more Advanced Techniques to
exploit the structure in the problem to
do parameter tuning in a better manner
okay so uh now I will move away from
this stand empirical risk minimization
problem where we were just working in um
generalized linear model um I'll try to
talk a little bit about the kernel
function based empirical risk
minimization problem so first let me
give motivation for why do we want to
worry about this kernel function based
ERM so in uh all this um work um that I
have talked about so far there is in
some sense inherent assumption that the
data is nearly linearly separable that
is uh
um like there can be a few points which
are nonseparable but at large the data
is reasonably separable but in practice
that may not happen so for example here
uh I will need a circle to separate out
those these two data points and there
actually I will have 100% accuracy but
in general this data is not linearly
separable so one of the major
achievements of machine learning has
been to um uh come up with techniques to
handle this problem so one approach is
that we'll uh because in let's say in
two Dimensions my data is not separable
maybe I'll project my data in three
dimensions and hope that it will be
separable there okay so for example for
this problem if I take X1 X2 and project
it to this three dimensional
space then the data immediately becom
separable you can find a hyper plane
with very good margin and you'll be able
to solve the problem uh
and another interesting thing here is
that the inner product of any two data
points is dependent only on the inner
product of x and z in low Dimension
space you don't even need to compute
this mapping explicitly you just can
compute the inner product of x and z and
that will give you the uh required inner
product
okay so um so let me now formly Define
the kernel function so suppose I have a
map from r to^ d which is my original
space to a much larger dimensional space
r to D5 and in fact D5 can be infinite
in several cases as well and a kernel
function is just defined as a function
over x and z in r^ D um that computes
inner product of these two high
dimensional um Hill Bird Space uh
vectors okay and there exist several
popular kernel functions some are very
nice and uh nice parametric functions
for example this Gan or RBF kernel or
polinomial kernel whereas uh in practice
people have come with certain kernel
functions which might not be this nice
so for example there is this pyramid
match kernel which is extensively used
in vision and Computing this kernel
function itself is um maybe 100 or 200
lines of code so it's not easy to
parameterize such kernel function you
can at most think of this kernel
function as a black
box okay so let me now discuss how this
kernel function comes in the picture of
our empirical ration so let's say I am
assuming a L2 regular empirical risk
minimization problem and I'm solving
over this over this really high
dimensional data where I'm hoping that
the problem is linearly separable and
that's why the optimal solution to this
uh problem will be
reasonable so here one thing to notice
that uh W hat is in the span of all
these vectors FX1 FX2 so on till
fxm and that observation is very easy
because suppose let's say I had an
orthon component then this orthonormal
component does not contribute anything
to the loss because all these pxi are
orthogonal to
w w perpendicular but it certainly adds
to my uh loss fun this regularization
function so this will give me a
suboptimal solution so this clearly says
that W Prime will be Z sorry W
perpendicular will be zero so now this
simple observation says that okay rather
than worrying about solving for entire W
hat I can just worry about solving for
alas so I'll reparameterize my problem
and now the problem is in terms of just
this Alpha hats and
uh there is no expressit dependence on
fee uh everything is in terms of these
kernel functions or these inner products
and these assumption that the inner
products can be computed efficiently
even though um Computing the mapping
file might not be possible at all like f
mapping can be finite dimension for
example in G kernels
okay so that's great but uh now the
question is can we apply um our
differential privacy techniques that we
Ed for the empirical risk minimization
problem that we saw in the linear case
the answer unfortunately seems to be no
because uh we cannot explicitly compute
this Vector W hat this W hat is
parameterized by this alpha eyes Okay so
this our solution itself is
parameterized by uh these Alp and my
training set so if I want to release my
um um parameter Vector W hat I have to
give out the training set also so there
is no question of uh preserving privacy
at
all and um note that I'm not assuming
any model over the kernel function so
kernel function can come from uh some
crazy um million line code and we might
not be able to extract any good property
out of it so we have no handle on for
given two points how the kernel function
will look
like okay so this sort of says that uh
differential privacy in general uh is
not my might not be
possible uh you had a
question Dimension that preses space
yeah but that will sort of assume some
goodness of the kernel
is well sometimes it's hard to figure
that out right so in order to assume I
mean need some goodness in the otherwise
over right and the more natural way
goodness have a large margin right sorry
the usual notional
goodness for the to be useful it has to
be a legal K it has to be satisfying
maybe an additional property like a
large margin property that allows you to
get good generalization bounds if you
have a large margin property you can
construct dimensional
mapping dimensional
mapping such the data is L separable in
dimens
no certainly you need uh certainly you
need this large margin property and the
issue is that in rest of the work we
never had to assume that we have large
margin property because whatever risk
that we get is compared to the best we
could have done with the hypothesis
space so in that sense um that is a
stronger assumption so the question is
can we do anything
better so so you don't get to do this
just assumption free in in the general
criminel case because usually if you're
not making assumptions on Mar or
something you're making assumptions on
the your kernel being bounded or
something like that that's a very strong
assumption the kernel being bounded is
strong sort of Tri why so let's say for
Gan kernel it's I understand that the
gausian kernel is found it but the
approximation rates that the gausian
kernel gets for interesting functions
like so F classes things like this are
extraordinarily slow right I mean I I
understand that we we do this but there
there are I mean you know Dean is right
if if if we're getting sort of certain
behaviors with the usual kernels then I
mean there's a lot of sort of functional
analytics stuff going on under the hood
that we need to be careful about a
little
bit that's a good
point so maybe you you'll mention this
but I I if I recall maybe if Kamali can
she or maybe Anna can comment that I in
fact a couple of the original papers
that looked at objective peration that
you cited earlier
mentioned that to deal with you know
kernel learning you you want to you
could project from the kernel space say
using this there's like the sampling
proc
sorry yeah but those things require
Assumption of the type that the kernel
is either uh translation invariant or it
is of the form something like
exponential inner product of XY and
that's why I say that um I might not
have any handle on the Kernel for
example in this pyramid match kernel the
kernel is completely
crazy do this for any car so if you give
me access to data can construct these
mappings that kind of preserve the nice
structure of the f space and
dimension all need access examples do
you need but do you need
like yeah yeah so so I certainly agree
but uh to bound the number of Dimensions
you will need the margin
uh margin you need something like one by
margin Square also it seems like the
projected sub space that you will come
up with is actually a function of the
data right have in the pure
differentially private model that
wouldn't really be private well you
would have to think about whether it's
private prior you get a prior then you
kind of make your own F data that CL the
real
dat one of the models might fit in that
sense so um so so in general uh with
without making any assumptions on kernel
or the how separation goes it seems like
we'll need to change the model little
bit so in this work with a we looked at
three models so one was extremely simple
interactive model where let's say I have
a database from which I get the super
chaining points there's a learner and
which learns a hypothesis or a parameter
Vector W and now a user comes in he
sends a test point to the learner and
learner just needs to give out the
prediction this is a fairly useful model
for for uh several problems let's say in
online setting where let's say user
comes in gives out a query and we just
have to answer the query on the Fly okay
you don't uh user does not demand uh the
parameter Vector itself he just needs a
prediction okay so so this model is uh
fairly um easy to handle I'll uh show
how uh how we can do it another model is
what I think uh every was referring to
which which is a sort of semi-
interactive model where I have a
database um and a from which I'm getting
supervise training points I have a
learner learns something which is uh
which might not be differentially
private and then a user comes in gives
his own test samples so whatever test
data he has he takes a small number of
samples from that and gives it to the
learner and now learner's job is to uh
release a vector W which will be
differentially private and hopefully
which will work as well as possible uh
as well as the original uh W star that
or W hat that he
Leed okay and uh so for this type of um
problem either you need a publicly
available test set or you need some sort
of scenario where let's say you have two
hospitals and a research lab both the
hospitals trust this research lab so
Hospital a sends this data training data
to research lab to find out uh um
find out the hyper parameter or let's
say support Vector Machine model and uh
Hospital a does not have any issue if
hospital if the research lab gives out
the parameter Vector as long as it
preserves his privacy so research lab
will ask the other hospital to give at
least a small sample from the test set
and because um the research lab is
trusted so the uh Hospital B will give
him the um
um give him the test samples which might
not be which definitely won't be labeled
and then using those test samples uh the
learner can learn uh a w private send it
to the to hospital B and Hospital B can
use it and in expectation it will still
be very good
okay so and then third model is this
non-interactive model where is the usual
model but we are assuming a parametric
form on the Kernel that is we are
assuming that the kernel is is a like is
clearly specified in parametric form and
it is function of these data points x
and z which are in R to power
D okay so let's first talk about the
interactive model where um we uh let's
say receive query ZT at the th step and
the prediction will be inner product of
w head with the F of ZT which is then
clearly parameterized by the alpha eyes
that the uh learner has the so Lear has
learned this alpi hat so it has that so
it's just inner product of alpha hat
with
KY okay so this is a simple uh uh linear
query that we need to answer for a
private database and it's a interactive
uh query release mechanism so we can uh
use this freeze Kernan uh IDC approach
of uh Gupta Roth andman and we can
privately release this um we can
privately release the uh
we can uh release uh the prediction uh
that are differentially private okay so
well uh the results are that um if we
have t queries then the algorithm is
absent differentially private um and the
risk for each of the query is bounded by
a quantity like this and here again we
have uh dependence on N is 1 by root n
Lambda and dependence on W is given by
Norm of w
Square okay so it's Al to
now note that getting if we have
Dimension dependence then that will
completely kill the problem because
dimensionality of the high dimensional
space is infinite so that won't be
meaningful at
all so the algorithm is this algorithm
by guptar andman which is based on this
work by morit heart and gy so the so the
algorithm is sort of um so you want the
your prediction W hat fzt to be so they
are maintaining uh a database WT at each
step and the guarantee is that the
database that they are maintaining is
differentially private okay and now if
for a given query if my prediction with
some small amount of noise far away from
the correct predition then I will make
an update and what you can show is that
the number of updates typically will be
very small because each update will
decrease the uh decrease the potential
function learn the database from the
side using the pr so what's what's the
form of the thing that you output W hat
is AAR combination of the kernel
functions evated as ZT yeah so what
we'll no no here we won't output W hat
all we output will output is something
like Alpha head in a product with K plus
some small amount of noise so so if uh
my prediction is correct then actually I
won't add even any noise I will have a
differential private version of this
Alpha heads let's call that Alpha T and
I'll just output that but if uh there is
too much of discrepancy then we'll
output this quantity plus a small amount
of Noise Okay so essentially your
support vectors will be amongst the test
points yeah support vectors will be
among test
yeah so so sorry do you do you ever
release no so this
is I'm sorry I think can's question is
basically mine so you're you release
this the kernel function the entire
kernel function evaluated on these Z
query
points so given a query point I might
not I so you create a new kernel
function which looks like the original
kernel function on your test set
distribution but is actually has it is a
linear combination of your ZTS
effectively you can just release the ZTS
no are best
points are submitting Z's fine what
you're releasing are the predictions B
are you releasing the predictions or can
you release Alpha hat is my question
Alpha you cannot release Alpha hat or
some some Alpha
which but releasing Alpha will not be
meaningful because Alpha each Alpha is
associated with fxi and I cannot release
F
fix oh maybe we can take this offline I
don't think
it
okay so uh the second model is the semi
interactive model where the user or um
yeah the user sends a small sample from
it test sample from his test data and
here what Kunal was saying was correct
that is uh we will indeed learn a kernel
over this test samples the test samples
that we release uh that that are given
to us and we don't have to worry about
differential privacy of these test
functions we'll learn it uh kernel
function over them so the idea again is
very simple that for we need to worry
only about the output each query and
we'll make each of these outputs
differentially private and the noise
that we need to add will be very small
because of low sensitivity of w hat okay
and now what we'll do is we'll try to
find out a w and and in some sense a
kernel over the query the test sets or
test data points that I'm seeing that
closely mimics the output that I'm
looking
for so over and the guarantees that so
well Epsilon Delta differential privacy
is clear and also because of this um
small amount of noise that we need to
add what we can see is that and because
we have random samples from the test uh
data set that's why by taking a small
number of those samples uh what we can
guarantee is that the uh performance of
w private on my test data will be very
similar to the performance of w hat and
it will be and it is
um uh like the excess risk is given by
something like 1 by root n epon
Lambda now here one thing which is at
first seems very surprising which is why
does do we why do we have a Lambda here
whereas in earlier bouns we never had a
Lambda like if you put Lambda to be
Infinity then the excess risk goes to
zero well um the explanation for that is
that in the earlier case
the test set and the training set were
coming from same distribution and what
we wanted was that our performance on
this distribution is good but here what
we are saying is that our performance on
uh the test distribution is as good as
the performance of w hat we are not
claiming that we will give best
performance on the test set that is not
possible because we don't even have any
labels from the test set all we are
saying is that whatever the learner
could have done in non private setting
we will do we will achieve the same in
differential privacy
setting and Lambda tending to Infinity
makes sense because if Lambda is
infinity then uh my w hat didn't learn
anything W hat was zero so w private can
also be zero and that's why I won't have
any excess risk but the risk of RW head
will be very
large is is that point clear so
essentially you have kind of two error
terms one which comes just from the
generalization from your training set to
the test set that's kind of hidden in RW
hat and then the second term is sort of
coming from privacy so uh RW hat need
not worry about training set
distribution at all right our W hat is
something that I've learned all I want
to say is that whatever W hat could have
done on my test distribution W private
should also be able to do that W hat can
be complete garbage I
don't right but you know so just looking
at the form you'd be tempted to make l
Lambda infinite but you're saying rfw
hat hides some dependency on
Lambda yeah so um if I make Lambda to be
infinite that says that W hat is not
learning anything from the training data
so naturally my access risk will be zero
but then the performance of w hat on the
test set might be
terrible so in particular let's say if I
assume that my training set and test set
have exactly the same
distribution then we can again apply the
same sort of things because because we
know that RW hat is bounded by RW star
the best I can do plus some term that is
dependent on Lambda like Lambda R W plus
excess risk and then I'll trade off
lambdas and get the error
B but here all we are saying is that on
test distribution we are doing as well
as the non private
learner okay and then finally uh we
consider this non-interactive model and
here again we think of uh so the problem
is again that we want to figure out uh
or we want to release a differentially
private uh parameter Vector W private
which essentially means that I want to
um uh I want I I want to come up with
the set of parameters so that for any
query I can make this linear prediction
in differentially private manner so one
approach that was suggested in in uh
this paper by uh Gupta Roth andman was
that suppose if I could so uh suppose I
if I could generate uh queries which are
worst case that is which will make me
enforce uh um like which will enforce
certain updates and because the number
of updates that I can do is very small
so after a small number of such updates
I will obtain a database or a parameter
Vector W private which is good and uh
which is good as in which performs well
well on uh unseen queries and which will
be differentially private however for
generating these worst case queries we
need to use the exponential mechanism
and that um leads to trouble because now
we need to sample from a distribution of
this type and here all we know is that
the inner product of FZ and WT is
characterized by the kernel function for
which we have certain parametric form
but we do not know how to efficiently
sample from this distri distribution so
this distribution is not neither lock
concave neither lock convex it's a very
arbitrary distribution even for very
simple kerners like Goan kernel or polom
kernel and so far we don't have any uh
efficient um algorithm for this setting
if the kernel function is a linear
function that is Fe is an identity map
then you can certainly sample from from
this this distribution using Gan uh like
using a mirrored gsan type of sampling
but then it's not very interesting
because linear kernel anyways we can
handle very
easily okay so there but assuming that
somehow we can sample from the
distribution what we observe is Epsilon
Delta differentially private solution
and the utility is given by um well the
excess risk that is that we have is
given by this and again the same caveat
applies here that what we want to do is
we want to find a private Vector W or uh
privacy preserving Vector W which is
as good as possible uh or which is as
good as W hat on the test
distribution and if we assume that the
test distribution training distribution
are same then again we can play this
game of um changing lambdas and obtain
uh
result okay so let me just uh summarize
what we have seen in this kernel
function based uh thing so uh in general
like if I'm assuming that um so in
general I might need to use Kel function
and especially in machine learning Kel
functions are very popular because uh
they help in giving more accuracy but if
I'm not um so but if I don't have any
control on how the kernel function uh
comes and let's say if I don't want to
make any extra assumption then the
problem seems um Hard to Handle in
general but uh we can relax it in uh
three uh meaningful models one is
interactive model another is semi
interactive model and then is non-
interactive model
in the non- interactive model we have an
inefficient method and it would be
interesting to see if we can come with
the efficient method to solve from uh to
sample from uh uh the distribution that
I described earlier okay
so uh let me now just summarize the
entire talk so uh empirical risk
minimation is a very nice framework to
study um generalization error of several
um uh algorithms and because it gives a
very crisp um notion of uh how good an
algorithm is that's why it's easy to
understand or study differentially
private algorithms also in this same
framework and goal of these differential
private algorithms is preserve privacy
and give small excess
risk and uh so for this problem we have
seen several algorithms and the
interesting part seems to be that
utility of all these differential
private algorithms depend on the
hardness of the problem which is very
critical that if your problem is hard
then certainly differential privacy
makes you lose quite a bit but if your
problem is easy then differential
privacy is uh is almost comes for free
okay uh now uh in several of the bounds
we have a dimension dependent term which
might not be avoidable in general but
assuming generalized linear model
tighter bounds are possible and then
there are several possibilities um for
applying differential privacy techniques
in like kernel online Lear learning Etc
so all these Frameworks are very similar
to this empirical risk minimization
framework okay so let me describe a
couple of open problems that I think are
very
interesting time okay so um one is U One
open problem is that uh so the for even
for the generalized uh linear model and
objective perturbation algorithm we
needed to assume that the um
regularization function comes from a L2
Norm ball or sorry is L2 nor square and
the problem is unconstrained so the
question is if I have any arbitrary
strongly convex function RW and possibly
constraint optimization problem then can
we achieve uh the correct regret or
correct excess risk
bound here again there's a caveat we
don't know dependence on optimal
dependence on Epsilon okay another
interesting open problem is that uh in
practice people do not do this
regularized empirical Mis minimization
especially um like you know if you are
working on some really um practical
systems a very na thing to do is just
take your uh empirical risk minimization
problem and without any regulation you
start from some random point and you
start doing gradient descent and rather
than optimizing uh your pro uh your
function completely you will just stop
after some small number of steps let's
say after 50 steps you stop or what you
do is you maintain a validation set see
how much error do you incur so initially
your error on the validation set
decreases and then at one point of time
it starts increasing so at that step
that point of time you stop and in fact
uh such early stopping methods have been
analyzed uh uh in certain settings for
example there's this work by garves
rashti and Martin Vite and then earlier
there was a work by Lorenzo Rosco and
Coors which analyz such early stopping
algorithms so one question is that can
we um use such early stopping algorithms
for providing differentially private
algorithms with good uh accesses and one
simple idea can be that let's say I have
multiple random initialization of um um
my U empirical risk minimization
approach uh we run for some fixed number
of steps stop take an average and most
likely the the the output that we uh
give will be differentially private the
question will be how good it is like
what will the utility analysis of such
an algorithm
that's not clear at PRI and another open
problem that I feel is pretty important
is uh semi supervis or differentially
private semi supervis learning so in
supervised learning we had this very
simple and very generic framework of
empirical risk minimization so the
canonical algorithm was very clear but
in semi learning the canonical algorithm
is not clear however there are some nice
uh theoretically sound algorithms for
this problem um such as this work by
Nina and aim and then there's also a
work by Zubin gamani and zeru so the
question is can we take those type of
algorithms and come up with a
differentially private algorithm with
good excess risk bound or good
generalization error bound and the same
time which provides good privacy
guarantees so thanks a lot for your
patient and some of the papers can be
done
more
questions in this early stuffing idea
that you mentioned uh you seem to
suggest that the Privacy part you sort
of you suggested that you might know how
to show that um but utility is the
problem I don't see how how you would
possibly argue def privacy perception
because that you you know for point you
just conver very
quickly uh no but uh that's why I said
that you'll have multiple ini
initialization so let's say I'm running
only for 50 iterations and maybe I'll
have th000 random initializations so
then when I average it out uh privacy
should work out so so the simplest case
is then when when I'm taking just one
step and I'm not taking any step and I'm
just giving random initialization so
that is private and then if I take one
step randomly then um assuming certain
um properties about the um about the
loss function
again I haven't proved it but it seems
like it should be possible to do but the
utility analysis definitely seems to be
more Yeah question I what about
something like data dependent
regularization think that would
be regularization priv as
well
okay does it
work can prove you can prove
but in some sense at least stopping is
indeed a data dependent regularization
because you have a validation set over
which you keep on
checking um so you were saying that for
objective
perturbation
uh makes takes advantage of the
complexity of the data yeah is there's
some St in which you think that might be
like like might be doing that optimally
maybe that can be maybe
shown because you're saying the bounds
are almost the same right I mean like
the worst case bounds are the same
should be some way to bring out but
the it's just that the bounds can be
much better let's say I have a uh linear
regression problem and I know that the
Coan Matrix has um you know um condition
number of the cious Matrix is very good
let's say it's constant then then that
immediately adds to my uh strong
convexity and I will have much better
bounds because the when I compute the
strong when the bounds come up we'll
have something like a 1 by Lambda and
term so this Lambda is now much stronger
like it's not just 1 by root but 1 by
root plus a constant so so what I have
mind is uh have this results for BCA
where they they have an algorithm that
kind of optimally takes advantage of
incoherence so you for something like
that right so there is you can get some
analysis of say objective perturbation
assuming that the loss function is
roughly quadratic and strongly convex
around the optimizer around the true
minimizer right um there's no reason to
think our analysis is I mean there's no
reason
that there's no argument that I know of
that shows that that dependency is
optimal um never mind the fact that it's
not particularly clean
either at that stage so let's take more
questions to the coffee break and we
continue
at